heartwrenching testimony from Tammy
Nobles during the mayorcas impeachment
hearing after her autistic daughter
Kayla Hamilton was brutally murdered by
a member of MS13 who was in this country
illegally Republicans on the house
Homeland Security committee voted to
move forward with impeaching my orcus
for his failure to secure the southern
border with a markup of the Articles
expected before the end of the month
join me right now in this Sunday morning
Futures exclusive to walk us through the
process is the chairman of the house
Homeland Security committee Congressman
Mark green Mr chairman thanks very much
for being here thanks Maria well this
really was hard to watch this testimony
by the woman who lost her daughter you
all are out until the end of January
when you get back on January 29th will
you walk us through how you will
approach impeaching Alejandra
mayorcas yeah Maria right now we are
assembling articles of impeachment to uh
present to our committee we'll mark
those up in committee very shortly after
getting back and then passing the
committee they'll go to the floor for a
vote on the
floor so the vote on the floor You're
Expecting in early February then I think
as very soon after you know one of our
challenges is just uh the folks that are
out for health issues right now but once
once those individuals get back I
anticipate a very quick vote on the
floor bottom line do you feel you have
the votes to impeach my orcus yes we
have the votes you have the votes and
and and are are are you seeing that as a
uh opening to actually get this done
what happens in the Senate do you
believe he will actually be out of the
job I I certainly hope so Maria look
this guy has subverted the laws passed
by Congress ignoring a co-equal branch
of government it's very clear the law
says shall detain and mayus has done
everything not to detain in fact he's
created systems that what he calls
lawful par Ro but it's actually totally
contradicting the immigration and
nationality act that was was passed by
this Congress the Executive Branch
executes the laws Congress writes laws
if if a cabinet secretary doesn't
believe in those laws he should run for
Congress and come over here and change
them he shouldn't just like a king do
whatever he wants and that's basically
what maricus has done and that's why
we're going after this impeachment it's
about the Constitution Maria it's about
the founding principles of our country
separation of power an executive branch
that executes and a legislative branch
that writes the laws he doesn't get to
write the laws or pick and choose well I
mean do you find it ironic that suddenly
uh President Biden claims he's been
telling everybody for 10 years that the
border is not secure I mean he just said
that of course we know we're two days
away from New Hampshire and 289 days
away from the presidential election it
appears the president is getting
religion now I think what's happening is
he's recognizing this is an 8020 issue
for the American people the American
people even Democrats I mean I have
Democrats that are my colleagues in the
house telling me that he should be fired
but it's it's unfortunate they're
probably going to vote to to not impeach
but but the truth of the matter is every
American recognizes that they're not
safe with this open border his Lawless
actions have resulted in uh you know
150,000 fentel deaths the cartels
metastasizing across our country
controlling the gangs that are in our
country and in our cities um of course
the terrorists you and I have talked
before on your weekday show about the
28,000 Chinese that have come into this
country in the last year many of the
military aid with prior associations
with the pla I mean we he has put the
National Security the safety of
Americans at massive risk and that
impact is because of his lawlessness he
has to go well we don't even know why
they're doing it why they're coming all
over here are they being directed by
xiin ping I mean 28,000 Chinese
Nationals military-aged Men We may
already have written the script of
what's about to happen to America what
why well I don't understand why they're
allowing it I can tell you that xiin
ping is he knows he saw what happened in
Ukraine the Russians infiltrated people
they immigrated into uh Western uh or
yeah eastern Ukraine and then they
basically when the attack happened those
those guys became the sabot tours now if
you look at the numbers prior to this
last year the highest number of Chinese
Nationals was 1,800 and suddenly in a
year it's 28,000 and you can't get a
plane ticket in China without a correct
social credit score the Chinese know
when you're flying El Salvador and come
into the United States well this is all
very disturbing and the reason that
we're constantly asking the question
whether or not Joe Biden is compromised
but let me go back to this impeachment
hearing why now why not a year ago I
mean you just heard your colleague
Michael McCall say we should have done
this a year ago and and we're still
talking about it you can understand the
frustration on the part of Republican
voters your constituents who say you all
can't get it
done Maria I'm frustrated I would love
to have done this a year ago but because
there are colleagues and and these are
some Republicans who think that there
ought to be a Judicial methodical uh due
process we did that in our committee we
did a five- phased investigation over
the course of the last year looking at
his dereliction of Duty looking at the
human cost of the country looking at the
financial cost of the country looking
for Waste Fraud and Abuse and and we
have finished that report in December
and now we're moving forward with the
impeachment we did that methodical
process to educate the American people
and hopefully educate a few Republicans
that felt that was a necessary process
all right Congress we're going to be
watching your work and of course those
articles of impeachment and the actual
impeachment come early February thanks
very much we will look to have you back
soon sir thank you hey it's Will Kane
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
Channel on YouTube it's the best way to
get our latest interviews and highlights
and click to subscribe to the will cane
podcast for full episodes right now